-Welcome back to the show.
-So good to be here.
-I want to talk about
"Barbarian."
But I have lots of things
to talk to you about.
First of all, I saw you
yesterday with Drew Barrymore.
-Yes.
-On her show.
And I thought that was
fantastic.
-It was so nice to see her.
It was so good to --
It was wild to do that
in front of --
You know, to reconnect
in front of strangers on TV.
-In front of America.
You met -- unbelievable --
another celebrity backstage.
-Yes.
-This is why I was laughing
when we were playing this game,
the last one,
you met the cornbassador
of South Dakota.
-Tariq.
He was so -- Yes.
-This kid is unbelievable.
-Yeah.
He was so cute, obviously.
Oh, big surprise -- he was cute.
-Yeah.
Big surprise --
he really was cute.
-It wasn't an act.
But I said to him, because,
obviously, he loves --
we all know he loves corn.
But I said,
"What are some of the things
you don't really like?
What are you not crazy about?"
-[ Gasps ]
This is an exclusive?
-This is a big scoop, guys.
So --
-This is gonna be all over
...tomorrow.
-Yeah, so I can report
that Tariq does not like
strawberries or peaches
or -- sorry to say --
"Sonic the Hedgehog 2," but he
loves "Alvin and the Chipmunks."
[ Laughter ]
So, he prefers a chipmunk
to a hedgehog.
Sorry, Ben Schwartz and everyone
in "Sonic the Hedgehog."
-I wanted to ask you,
while I had you here,
'cause I know
you're a great actor,
but you're also very good
at doing impressions.
We've always done them
to each other backstage.
-Yeah, people love it.
People around us are...
-I hope people love it.
-...not at all annoyed by our...
-No. Here's you.
This is in --
This is in "Walk Hard:
The Dewey Cox Story."
-Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
-And you were George Harrison.
-Oh, man.
It was a thrill.
-With Paul Rudd,
Jason Schwartzman, Jack Black.
-And the great --
-John C. Reilly.
-I mean, these are all
my favorite -- not myself.
All my --
some of my favorite performers.
And so I got this call --
-Were you nervous
to play with the Beatles?
-I was because it was --
You know,
the stakes couldn't be higher.
It's the Beatles.
If you like music,
you love the Beatles.
And I grew up listening --
you know, we both --
Everyone loves the Beatles.
I don't have to make that point.
So, I got --
-Judd called you?
-Judd called and said, "I want
you to play George Harrison."
And I of course said yes.
And, um,
we had a day to prepare.
And so I called Paul Rudd,
who --
It's a very name-droppy story,
but you mentioned him, also.
Paul was playing John Lennon.
And I said,
"Paul, you know, I'm nervous.
We're playing the Beatles."
And he's like,
"Dude, I'm nervous, too.
I know, we only have a day."
And so I went over
to his hotel room.
And we just watched
as much footage as we could
of the Beatles
in interviews and stuff.
And while we were there,
Jason Schwartzman called.
He was playing Ringo.
And he said,
"Dude, I'm so nervous.
Are you guys nervous?"
And so, the three of us were,
you know, sharing our nerves
with each other.
And as we were watching them,
I never really realized
how distinct they all were.
You do such a great --
-How does Paul go?
-Well, Paul -- Paul's very --
you know, with him, it's --
I like to, like,
hook into something.
Like, if it's a word
or just sort of a look.
And he's got his eyebrow
always kind of up like this.
And it's very sing songy,
you know?
And he says, "you know," a lot.
You know, up and down.
-Yeah, you know, yeah.
-It's sort of like this.
-We're the Beatles, you know.
Yeah.
-And we're doing this.
-That's good.
-And then, John is --
There's something kind of
nasally about John.
You know, John's very --
It's all kind of directed
through the nose there.
-Yeah, he's very nasally.
Speaking only through his nose.
-Sort of like that, yes.
And Ringo, you have to --
It's the least flattering --
the most unflattering.
You kind of have to put
your head back like this.
And Ringo kind of acts
like this.
But I thought, "George --
What is George's hook?"
And I realized it was just --
He's just -- He's just
so contemplative, you know?
And everything
is sort of like this.
And, of course,
I was sad when John died.
But it was -- you know,
I knew -- I knew --
I was sad because I'd never
play guitar with him again.
-Wow, wow, wow!
That is good!
You can do all the Beatles!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So, then, were like --
So at the end of this --
at the end of this, you know,
session with Paul,
I'm leaving Paul Rudd,
I'm leaving his hotel room,
and he said -- you know,
I shouldn't tell you --
I said, "I wonder
how Jack Black's feeling."
You know, 'cause Jack's
gotta play Paul McCartney.
And Paul said,
"I shouldn't tell you this,
but I ran into Jack
the other day,
and I asked him that.
I said,
'Dude, aren't you nervous?
We're playing the Beatles.'
And he said,
"No, dude, I got it.
It's in the bag."
[ Laughter ]
And Paul goes,
"How did you do --"
He goes, "Dude,
just watch 'Hard Day's Night.'
That's all you gotta do
is watch 'Hard Day's Night.'"
So, we were like,
"Oh [bleep] no."
-Dude.
Dude, it's in the bag.
-Dude, it's in the bag.
-I got it, dude.
I [bleep] got it, dude.
[ Laughter ]
And so, were like,
"Oh, Jack's gonna
blow us all out of the water.
-Yeah, of course he is.
-And so we show up on set.
And Jack's got the first line
in rehearsal.
And he goes --
he's got the outfit on.
He's doing the eyebrows.
You know,
he's got that kind of going.
And he goes --
he's right here, and he goes,
[ Scottish accent ]
"I'm Paul McCartney, eh?
[ Laughter ]
Like, full-on Scottish.
And I looked at Rudd,
and we're like,
"What's going on?"
And -- but --
But the lesson that we learned,
which we shouldn't
have needed to learn,
is that Jack
still stole the show
because he's [bleep] Jack Black,
and he's the greatest
of all time.
-Yeah, of course.
Don't worry.
Don't overthink it.
-Yes, exactly.
We were overthinking it.
And he was just --
He's like, "Everyone knows
I'm not Paul McCartney.
I'm Jack Black."
And it was so funny.
It was so good.
He was brilliant.
-I love Jack Black.
Everyone loves Jack Black.
-He could do that.
Let's talk about the --
you're in the number-one movie
right now in the country,
"Barbarian."
Congratulations on this.
-Thanks, man.
-Frightening.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So fun.
It's fun.
-Scary movies
getting great reviews.
How did you feel
when you found out
it was the number-one movie
in the country?
-It was exciting.
I got a text --
I was in my place, which you've
been to up in Massachusetts.
I live in kind of
a rural area up there.
And all of my neighbors
are over 70.
And I got this text
from the director, Zach Cregger,
who's brilliant, and he said,
"Hey, we got
the number-one movie."
And I said -- I said it to them.
I was proud.
I had a moment where I said,
"Hey, you guys,
I'm in the number-one movie."
And they said, "Oh, yeah?
What's it called?"
I said, "It's 'Barbarian.'"
And he said, "Oh, okay."
And one of them said,
"Hey, by the way,
why aren't you ever
watering your garden?"
And I said,
"Uh, what do you mean?"
He goes, "You're never here.
You're never here.
And Mick's
having to water your garden."
-They could care less.
-Care less.
-They can care less
about this movie.
-And I said, "Well, I've been
promoting this movie."
He goes, "Promoting?
What do you have
to do that for?"
He says,
"You gotta water the garden."
[ Laughter ]
And as I was leaving,
I said to Mick -- I said,
"So, are you gonna
go see 'Barbarian'?"
He goes, "Oh, yeah.
I'm gonna go
to the local multiplex,"
the joke being
there's no movie theater
anywhere near where I live.
So, they're not gonna watch it.
-They're not gonna watch it?
That's a good
humble pie there for you.
-It was.
It was -- everything's relative.
-I love Zach Cregger,
by the way.
He's great.
He wrote and directed this.
-Yes.
-He's talented.
-From The Whitest Kids You Know,
the sketch comedy group.
-Talented guy.
-Really brilliant.
-But it's frightening.
-It is.
It's scary.
It's wild.
And there's some turns.
And it's one of those movies
that we're supposed to be
talking about it,
but we're not supposed
to say anything about it.
So it's a little challenging.
-Yeah, well, I guess that's the
fun part of these scary movies.
Because you're like,
"Well, don't spoil it."
Because every single thing
could be possibly a spoiler.
-Totally.
And it is.
It really is.
The twists and turns are wild.
They're fun.
-Well, we could say
someone moves into a --
rents a house.
-No.
No.
Don't say --
Yeah, we can say --
Sorry, sorry.
We can say
there are people in it.
-Okay.
-No, no.
Yeah, someone rents a house.
Someone rents a house.
-An Airbnb.
Yeah, it's an Airbnb.
That'll sell it.
Someone rents a house.
-Yeah.
That's a great story.
Someone rents an Airbnb.
-No, sorry, Jim.
Wait, sorry.
They rent a house,
and it gets double-booked.
So, Bill Skarsgard
and Georgina Campbell,
who are so good, they --
they find themselves together
in this --
Not an Airbnb,
it's a scare-bnb.
-Ooh-ooh-ooh-ooh!
-Ooh-ooh-ooh-ooh! Yes!
-Is there anything you learned
from making this film
for the future?
Anything you're like, "Oh."
-I would just say I love Airbnb.
It's a great company.
They do a lot of
great work with --
-Yeah, yeah, of course.
-But I would say,
check the basement.
That's what I'm gonna do
from now on.
Wink.
-That's all you gotta say
right there.
That is the best way
you could ever sell this movie.
-Yeah.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Justin Long
in "Barbarian."
Take a look at this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hello?
-I like to let my baby determine
how long he likes to nurse.
-Oh, God.
[ Tape measure unspooling ]
[ Tense music plays ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Justin Long!
"Barbarian" is in theaters
right now.
Ellie Goulding performs for us
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.